so me and the whole bridal party were
roommates freshman year and everyone
said I was gonna be the first one to get
married and now I'm the only one who's
not which is crazy I can't do this
anymore there's more than one type of
the team and I'm not gonna fulfill some
stereotypes just to make somebody happy
I'm sorry given under their jugular from
Marcus oh yes I am a very important
decision how are you defining sex if
there's to matter to women how would you
define sex with multiple simultaneous
partners or what if somebody's undergone
genital reconstruction or or is it
yourself
it was just so more like you know does
that make sense my delicates you just
decanted white wine it needs to breathe
[Music]
back in the day you say we have to call
people like this day that's what's up
nicholas copernicus on into this in
continuity knows Cavalia tranquilo
therapy you tell me
you know mr. Markham Swami come in peace
okay sure
[Music]
what do you say that
hey get back here I'm not done I'm not
did I say I was done